بعد أكثر من 30 عامًا ، أصبحت الولايات المتحدة  من المقرر
أن تنسحب من
اتفاقية نزع السلاح النووي البارزة ، معاهدة
القوات النووية متوسطة المدى أو معاهدة القوات النووية متوسطة المدى في
واشنطن ، قائلة إن روسيا تغش
إما أننا إما ندفن رؤوسنا في الرمال ،
لكننا نتخذ إجراءات منطقية ردًا
على تجاهل روسيا الصارخ لما تم
التعبير عنه  شروط معاهدة
الصواريخ النووية متوسطة المدى وهذا هو نظام الصواريخ الذي تقول الولايات المتحدة
إنه ينتهك معاهدة الصواريخ النووية
متوسطة المدى 9 م 7:00 إلى 9:00 موسكو
تنفي المزاعم وتزعم الولايات المتحدة  هو
الشخص الذي يخرق الصفقة
حتى أن الجيش الروسي وضع موجزًا يعرض نظ
م 9m 7 إلى 9 ويدعي أن نط
قه يقع ضمن حدود INF التي نف
تها روسيا وتواصل تنفيذ مت
لبات المعاهدة بدقة ولا تسمح بأي من
ا  الانتهاكات التي ستحدث تم
التوقيع على معاهدة القوات النووية متوسطة المدى في عام 1987 من قبل الرئيس رونالد
ريغان والزعيم السوفيتي ميخائيل
جورباتشوف بهدف القضاء
على الأسلحة النووية متوسطة المدى الأرضية اليوم ، ترى كل من روسيا
والولايات المتحدة المعاهدة على أنها عفا عليها الزمن إلى حد كبير
لأنها تقيد -
بينما الدول غير الموقعة.  مثل الصين
حرة في استخدام أسلحة نووية متوسطة المدى
تدعي موسكو أنها تريد
محاولة تحويل معاهدة القوى النووية متوسطة المدى إلى معاهدة متعددة الأطراف
لمحاولة إنقاذها ، نحن منفتحون على
أفكار مختلفة حول كيفية دفع الأمور
إلى الأمام ، ولا نستبعد
أي شيء قبله موسكو  يقول إنه إذا
فشلت معاهدة INF ، فقد يؤدي ذلك إلى سباق تسلح جديد
ويزيد من خطر
نشوب صراع نووي ما يقرب من ثلاثة
عقود بعد نهاية الحرب.  الحرب الباردة
لك